uh uh listen we we can't use this stats
to say much because if we break those
stats down for reasons why and you look
at the pairings and you know how number
one reason is financial okay so let me
tell you something about finances yeah
as a man if you're meant to be a
provider if you are with a woman that
earns more than you she may leave you
but it's not always because she's August
and she thinks she's better than you a
lot of the time when you are more likely
to leave after a promotion yeah but wait
like a lot of the time when you are
doing more than your man is in the field
that he's supposed to be doing more than
you are because he's going to then act
out against you not because you he how
do you know they're not acting out
against him and acting like they're
better than him because he can go both
ways okay and that's why when we use
these stats we need to look at the
reasonings why because a lot of the time
men get really upset because their woman
is doing better than him and that makes
him feel emasculated to leave your
husband because he's upset no because if
he if he treats me like crap because I'm
making it because deep down he knows I'm
making more money he's making him feel
some type of way and he's not making me
happy of course I'm gonna have to leave
I'm not gonna like quit my job so that
you can feel better about yourself about
the kids happiness and not yours the
case happen is dependent also my
happiness but why because if I'm because
I think happiness is a choice
um it is a choice and that's why you
make the right choices if it's a choice
then why can't you be happy
well I can't be happy but if there is
somebody in my life that is who's having
unhappiness is affecting mine because
energies are contagious then I have to
separate myself especially even for kids
this is the thing sometimes we think
that for children the best things for
parents to be together no I mean best
because statistically well the best
thing the best thing for kids when when
um when they are young growing up is to
have a healthy loving relationship being
shown in front of them if you two are
not getting on as a married couple at
least separate but keep the love for the
child because at the end of the day it's
not about you and the person being
together about that kid growing up
healthy with mental and emotional
stability depending along why can't you
just live in separate rooms live in
separate houses why because living in
separate rooms well I want it's better
for the kids to have two parents in the
home you know what I genuinely but see
this is like a modern mindset where it's
like me me me first my happiness first
before my own children and like that I
think that's why we have like a very
[__] up society today because it's me
me me my happiness me because your
happiness directly affects somebody if
I'm depressed
like okay if I'm in a terrible
relationship it's like okay you can just
figure out how to get along with people
well I think it's important right if if
they are important and put things aside
that you're compromising your values
you take in front of God I would say all
Society very much is about individualism
now because like capitalism is
fundamentally based on individualism and
so therefore you you feed into your own
values now so now when you're in a
marriage you think what do I want not
what my husband or partner wants right
now
problematic because it makes it more
competitive the market and it makes your
teaching I think it's a problem because
it's not supposed to be about you it's
supposed to be about the family exactly
supposed to be especially the kid like I
just think as a mother you should want
your kids to be happy Above All Else But
if you're sadden your relationship
surely that's gonna transpire our kids I
know but I'm saying I'm saying I'm
saying like why can't you just put that
aside but let's say raise your kid raise
your kids and then after that you could
focus on your happiness because it takes
two it takes two seven of the practice
is that as a child you learn by example
and if you watch your parents argue or
you watch your mum constantly compromise
her values and say fine learn not to
argue yeah but the fact you're not to
get learn to get along but what if
you're like I don't want to do that and
you always see your mum being like I
don't want to do that in your and your
father is forcing her to do that you
learn growing up that you're that what
you want doesn't matter and you just
have to force yourself to do what you
don't like and that could put you in
really harmful situations don't you
think you're saying to teach these young
girls to be complacent like see their
mothers just speak in placement of the
fact they're unhappy with this man put
the family above you but some I'm not
saying I'm saying I don't I'm not for
abuse so and completely if it's an
abusive situation that's different yeah
but but
I think I think I think wait okay I
think happiness just comes and goes
and I think there were a lot of times my
parents have been married 30 years and
there have been a lot of times where my
mom maybe wasn't happy for a couple
years or my dad maybe wasn't happy for a
couple years but because of us they
stuck it out and they got happier and
they learned to work it out and they
learned to get along and I think a lot
of times in our society we we throw in
the towel before we've even really tried
and I think that's the average length of
a first marriage is seven to eight years
in a household rather not be together
like as a couple but in front of the
kids you can just be united front yeah
but then you can live your own private
lives
but you live together like you see right
I think if you'd going into on a
marriage thinking that you're going to
be happy you're going in for the wrong
reasons because just like Pearl said
they're going to be situations where
you're not going to be happy just
because you're not happy you're going to
leave now no if you if you stand before
that Court you stand before you sign the
paper you agreed to that to life to
worst to better and not just because
you're happy you have kids involved no
it's not about your happiness anymore
because the fact that you two gonna stay
there that's gonna that's gonna greatly
impact the child's life so if we're not
talking about no extreme cases about you
know like any um you know sa going on at
home and any abuse or whatever
in your I don't want to put it so
bluntly but it's not about your
happiness your life is not yours anymore
you're raising kids now that's the sense
of your life so forget your happiness
work it out look at our grandmas talk to
our great great numbers they went you
think that they're going to hell right
they will see their man cheating but
they say look I got kids so I gotta put
my kids before me because I know they
need me in the house and I think that's
like even you said we become way more
individualistic now and is that even to
our benefit look at the results it's not
doing us any good okay so just taking
off what you said and the whole it's
about the the family so your idea of
it's about the family is okay let's just
say you're like because you're talking
about a very specific situation the ups
and downs of a marriage where you can be
unhappy happy happy that's fine and I
think most people would agree on you you
need to ride the highs with the lows but
if you've got a situation where let's
just for the sake of this argument we've
got a woman and her daughter or even
like actually even flip it a man and his
son and that's this dude is habitually
unhappy like every day just unhappy
miserable whole family feels it all the
kids feel it you're like yo but you're
staying there you're putting your family
first but you're teaching this boy this
is what marriage looks like this is what
wait wait this is what a family looks
like so he then goes on to have his own
family where he's habitually unhappy and
then he teaches his son to do so you
have this line of people just unhappy
but married but like this idea of a
family together wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait let me just let me just
something about happiness it's about
Duty exactly
and I understand that but I don't think
like because to me you're like as long
as you are together that's the most
important thing and you stay together
like even if you're unhappy even
basically it is
because you're more likely to run away
from home you're more likely to go to
jail you're more likely to get bad
grades in school every statistical
disadvantage you can put a kid at
they're at when you take the father out
of the home what about yourself and so I
what I'm saying is that it's marriage is
not about happiness it's about Duty okay
and then my best friend everyone's what
Mario best friend have a baby with your
best friend like is your friend with
benefits but you have a child so it's
easy because you respect each other you
love each other and you don't really
need to argue
regardless there there is going to be an
unhappy time and like I said we can't
base a marriage off of happiness because
if if you come into a stinking look I'm
gonna get married with this love of my
life because they treat me well and
they're gonna treat me like a queen I
can be happy for the rest of my life no
because they're gonna be a day you might
go to a financial hardship you might go
to a health situation is that going to
be the breaking point you're like okay
no I'm not happy not going to leave no
you got kids so you're responsibility if
I had to take why can't we figure out a
solution just tell them like if you're
really unhappy why can't you figure out
a solution maybe maybe it's maybe it's
sleeping in separate bedrooms for a
couple years till you figure out how to
maybe maybe it's wait sorry maybe it's
marriage counseling maybe it's sleeping
in separate bedrooms for a couple years
maybe be it's I don't know consoling
with your church family whatever it is
but it's like why why is the first go-to
always divorce divorce divorce I
understand that and I get that and okay
yeah I get that and okay I get that in a
case where you're like you've got two
people and they both like you've at
least got two people and they're willing
to work on it or whatever but what if
you've got a situation where you have a
person who is like I want to stay and
let's just say it's fundamentally there
are these things you do that make me
unhappy and that person like I'm not
gonna and right so you should carry so
you so what's the answer then like if
you've got this situation where someone
is like I'm doing my thing and I'm
living and I'm not changing so the
unhappy person example of an actual
situation okay cool so to like narrow it
down so 100 uh you've got a man and he's
married to a woman and he fundamentally
is like so so to me the underpinning is
this is my thinking he chose wrong when
he married this woman okay and the
reason is he wants someone who
fundamentally is submissive to him
that's what he wants and when that
doesn't when that doesn't manifest he
feels belittled in himself in front in
front of his kids in front of his family
and this woman does
she submits performatively so she's like
oh yeah I'll cook for you I'll cook but
when they have an agreement and he's
like I need you to move right she's like
nah that's not a good enough reason I'm
moving left and that constantly happens
they go to through therapy and that's
essentially the Crux of it she's like I
wasn't raised that way
um like my mum wasn't like that I'm not
gonna be like that whatever so and this
man is now happy she is not happy you're
like for Duty sake the family stay
together anyway yeah and I think
marriage should be based on
sustainability like can she sustain that
long term no I would say until the kids
are 18 I would do everything I could to
figure it out until the kids are 18.
what just give up all like sense of
morality and happiness and like even if
it is jeopardizing with your mental
health and like even things like that
like just stay what do you mean all
sense of morality I need you to be like
he was saying about like oh that's how
my mother was raised like if it's going
against your morals in there like like
not forcing you but like asking you to
be someone that you're not like that's
your you're giving up all the sense of
I will give Will Smith a divorce
base your relationship off your parents
relationship and if you watch your mum
or your dad constantly belittle
themselves and constantly let themselves
get walked over you're going to let
yourself get walked over because
if you're their gender because it's more
likely to be the woman you're going to
think oh it's okay I mean it's more
likely to be the woman because like
domestic violence you're more likely to
be domestically abused especially most
most um domestic violence is two-sided
like a lot of girls claim domestic
violence but they hit first okay um and
you're actually more likely to be in a
domestic violence um where if it's
one-sided abuse like women are more
likely to be in uh more likely to hit
men once I did than men are to hit women
okay fine well whatever gender is your
whatever gender gets belittled you're if
you're that gender You're Gonna Let
Yourself Go walked over like that so do
you think people should just like never
get divorced is that like your position
yeah like do you think should divorce
should just be like illegal like yeah
okay we'll sniff the divorce you said
that like you said that they should try
their hardest is Johnny Depp married I'd
give that man a divorce you're like in
some situations divorce is legitimate
yeah said in front of God you said you
made your vows in front of God and let's
face it in the UK for richer or poorer
for sickness and in health
God has less value
so much
to you not not to people wait wait wait
wait not to people of Faith but
statistically but this is the as a
country we have belonging but not
believing true true however however
that's why marriage is outdated that's
why why we're in a post-meritance
society that's why that wait wait that's
why people are getting married less and
less and less what's people's
justification that they're saying the
marriage isn't working out because they
can't say any more God God wants me to
do this what do they say to themselves
when they're unhappy and they're in a
situation it's about my kids
you do acknowledge there are situations
where divorce is acceptable to you of
course yeah okay but here's my point
do you not think the two people involved
in that marriage are the best people to
judge when that situation has arrived
yeah I think if that was true I don't
think it would be a 50 divorce rate
I don't think I don't think the number
one reason wait I don't think the number
one reason would be financially yes but
that doesn't exist in the vacuum though
like there is other things like that
changes when you add more details like
are they more educated than it like I
think it lowers or if they're if they
come from a two-family home where
everyone is still married then it goes
up like it's there are things that
change yeah it's bad so it's not like
you know every time you get married it's
a coin flip it depends on your personal
situation and things some situations
that are better and worse true yeah and
there's some situations you're like you
should get divorced in your mind yeah
exceptions not the rule I don't I don't
think 50 of marriages should end in
divorce and my whole point but like
you're missing my point because you're
trying you're trying to like get me
wait wait it's the whole point is that
we have a me me culture where it's me
and my happiness before the family and
where I think I should put my feelings
before the family in extreme situations
sure I believe in divorce Will Smith I
don't know if Johnny Depp was married to
that woman but I'll give you both
divorces I'll get wait wait I'll give
you both divorces but in general it's
like we just have such a selfish like
modern women are selfish yes and and
it's weight and and it's about me before
my family and I just think that's wrong
but it's reflective of the society we
like in the UK in America we have very
capitalist societies and that is
individualism and if you were in a more
socialist society where it was more
about the community then you would find
families wouldn't splurp as often and
and the fact is it's not just women and
like men and women equally are because
women is leaving women are the ones
leaving women leave 70 to 80 percent of
this
wait when women leave 70 to 80 percent
of the time 90 of their college educated
if anything I think women become more
selfish because we're build out of every
bad decision
wait so yes
weight no
no because every time we make a bad
decision we're bailed out if we're bad
with our money there's women's shelters
if we sleep around there's birth control
if we get pregnant we can have an
abortion it waits if we if we don't get
the abortion and we get married they can
we can divorce them and take half
or we can put the kid on child support
child support not Ted as well
um when it comes to marriage
that there's almost no incentive for a
man to leave
um more often than not there are men
that he was just he who are still
breathing about dying everything as
we're speaking right now so it's like
what you lose from a man leaving the
marriage in comparison to women even
marriage it's just it's more
incentivized for women to leave it's
just facts as a man a woman's going to
take off your money and you probably
won't have access to your kids that's
why it's cheaper to keep it you know
yeah most men would literally rather
just like just fade as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible